hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of red lifts orange crowd I'm
Alana today I'm joined by IGN's Andrew
called fog hello and roosterteeth Blaine
Gibson hola otherwise known as my
boyfriend yes hey what's up hey doing
good how are you yeah I'm doing all
right why am I asking that we've been
hanging out literally all day I haven't
seen you in such a long time we never
talked also swarthy don't ask me it's
fine whatever I see though I was doing
very well this is a show where we talk
about misconnections mine's a short one
this one is called my dog had diarrhea
in Warby Parker and you held him woman
for man this is actually from Austin oh
it's very short my dog had a diarrhea
accident in the wall me pocket in the
domain and this nice cute guy held him
for me while I cleaned up my dog's mess
I think he said his name was Josh but
that's all I know
bawdy athletic height 5 5 status single
weight an age 31 that's the whole story
I thought really is Josh the one that
she's looking for or yes she's nice Josh
she's trying to know it says I think he
said his name was Josh so she's trying
to find a nice cute guy named Josh who
okay it's unclear but it sounds to me
like he was holding her dog was all he
had
diary no no I assumed the dog had
diarrhea and he held the dog while she's
away from the diarrhea like like so the
dog wasn't like eating in or making the
situation worse in some way spreading
the diarrhea to because I don't think he
was holding it wallet ice-cream machine
it's weird because okay
the domain is where I took you for the
Pokemon goes that's right up there
briefly yeah but also I know a guy named
Josh that fits that description I'm
wondering you and nice athletic 5 foot 5
oh this would be the person who posted
this status I don't know please atletic
in five five yes okay that's not that I
thought you were saying he was five five
hours like that for lucky because I
heard dude and I'm by beat so it's like
you could be like I don't see any reason
why people couldn't post the other
person's body types but I don't actually
know I don't know if there's a
stipulation of like rewards your body
specs
like I'm not actually sure if that's the
thing on the important question here is
what was the breed of dog yeah does not
say yeah the color and consistency of
the diagram what's it won't be pakka
Warby Parker's a glasses company oh yeah
it's like a pretty nice one they're like
their whole thing is that they're like
very like they had like showrooms that
are like really fast so also it says
inside of the Warby Parker it's not
saying like in the domain which I've
been there which is like kind of an
outdoorsy there's like it's like an
allergies you hang up so yeah it had
diary inside the silver be pakka
yeah so I want to know how this
interaction went down and that your dog
has diarrhea how do you go about asking
a nice cute guy to hold it for you I'm
sure he offered yeah you think I mean if
I walked in and saw someone bent down
cleaning up their dogs diarrhea and the
dogs all like bothering them I would
totally like hold the dog like I don't
feel like that's that unnatural yeah
yeah I guess you're right you'd like
probably offer to do it if you want to
be away from the diarrhea most people
would be like get the [ __ ] out of this
that she losses shop while this dog [ __ ]
everywhere
you might be like like us though that we
don't know none of us own dogs and we
want any sort of contact with dogs but
hanging out hanging up I still I still
do that dog that's a good point so like
maybe it was really cute yeah he's a
labrador puppy and they're like you know
what yeah
thank you worth it we all have blood
problems sometimes I also why I was like
that person in the Gloucester Shop not
helping cuz it says she was she was just
cleaning it up you're like well would
the attendant it's it's an incredible
scenario of thinking of like all these
people trying on glasses and like eight
employees just staring unmoving staring
with like their mouths a Gabe while this
man holds a dog and a woman cleans up
that I like to think that like she's
walked in to get some like glasses
whatever random thing but it's like you
know this really nice setting it's all
pristine and white it's all organized in
a way that looks like an IKEA catalog
and there's like I love you okay - music
playing and everything's beautiful just
rich people like shopping for glasses
and then it's just like Oh rich people
are just gossiping everywhere like oh
I'm pretty sure if I know faints like if
I know a dog the dogs probably trying to
look at its butts like hail and he's
going in circles and just further
spreading to die
the funny thing for me is I don't have
diarrhea realistically right like it was
probably like a tiny little thing of
diarrhea but I am picturing this place
over yeah like I'm picturing like all
the glasses have diarrhea all over them
I'm absolutely picturing a giant puddle
usually like if dogs have like sloppy
poops then you only find out about it
after it's done the poopy like oh that
was a sloppy one that's this is a
conversation dog on his half oh yeah
you'll be like I was a sloppy one today
it was unpleasant to pick up how did you
get that into a bag like when you're a
part if it's in gross it's [ __ ] old
dig up the grass I mean like the way
that we always picked up dog poop like
while I was growing up it's like you put
your hand inside of a bag and then pick
it up yeah yeah yeah they're like solid
it's [ __ ] difficult when it's yeah
you I feel like at that point it's like
you handle it like pee and then you just
ignore it right yeah
no this thing's in the ground well I
mean maybe that'll be better because it
would like eventually harden and then
you would just be able to like kind of
peel it up like a low pass just come
back three days later it's like setting
like a something in the oven it's ready
remind me in three days I had my first
soup I actually if this person is five
foot five in their name is Josh I know
that it's not but anyways my friend Josh
has a husky he was taking it on the
metallic trail for sure but oh no
question it's a good husky that the
husband had diarrhea on Town Lake and he
had to clean up the diarrhea with his
bare hands
ah and he like posted the pictures very
like y'all I just wouldn't even do that
wait so this is that same guy is this
guy like really and the diary is it's
like a weird twist to this like he's not
is the woman at all he's just like he
heard that a dog at diarrhea he came
across town at the domain ran in to get
his hands on that just wondering like
how often does your dog have bowel
problems
cool wanna hang out every week Oh hit me
up like let me know that's messed up
if someone that you thought was cute if
this happened would you be be weird
enough we had it out enough by them that
you would never see them again
no it's not their fault if anything I
find weird [ __ ] like this like enduring
it's like having a good story is like a
really good foundation for like the
beginning of really yeah it's like oh we
met over tinder
oh my dog [ __ ] everywhere and he held it
that's romantic
is kind of romantic it's gross because I
imagine it's like both an embarrassing
and emotional situation like imagine if
you had a really bad day and then your
dog has diarrhea in a nice store yeah
you're just like everything's going
wrong today and then handsome nice Josh
walks in and holds your dog while you're
cleaning up we haven't any like Oh Josh
I'd like to imagine while you're having
a bad day that song is playing on the
radio
it's just rank people up like you know
like you had a bad day but now you have
what a great library they're like ooh
you had a bad day yeah I don't know it
depends on the time it's actually the
unedited version is you're at a bad day
idiot you just drop some insults in
there so we have to give this person a
name I mean we could just go with Josh
but the idea is to give the woman a name
I was gonna say like Charlie like
Charlie and shock factory because those
thing a poop or wagon what's the name
that sounds almost like diarrhea Diana
Diana Diana
let's go Atari around I let's just
invent sure so I broke the rules in I
only asked for one I have two one of
whom is a very quick one we can just
brush it to the side mm-hmm
favor delivery David you delivered to me
this morning I'm on the third floor and
answered the door with my boner poking
out through my shorts you seem surprised
but looked interested were you tell me
where the food was from and let's see if
we can find each other anyway bye how'd
you meet your husband well one of the
ones that I like read but decided not to
have a share on the show was you stood
next to me at a urinal and you had a
boner
and then I got a boner and then we
washed our hands and went separate ways
anyway were you interested so this is
like two dudes standing next to each
other
urinals both getting bonus and god gold
just like we both paid and then had
bonus for a mint and then left
well now I'm trying to figure out and
this this is based out of Austin I guess
I should clear this is a man for man
I don't know it doesn't say no I infuse
because it would be this could be the
same guys the bathroom incident where
the guy making the delivery also got a
boner and then he left either way I
think it's pretty [ __ ] up on whoever
answered the door with a boner poking
out you know poking at doesn't like
coming through the hole in his boxers
cuz that's like that's what I pictured
right it was just like hooking forward
yeah yes it poking at you through my
shorts through my shorts yeah sounds
like the zipper was down he was just
like I think it's probably you saying
like you sorry boxes and it's just like
shorts yeah assuming using loungewear
which is typically like a mesh shorts or
something like a robe you know how
people say that like like to hide
Bonin's in school whatever you like tuck
it behind your belt you know if you're
wearing like a shut would that just be
obvious you just got like a weird like
snake thing running up to your belly
button
yes it's less noticeable but you
wouldn't be able to tell you wouldn't
like it wouldn't be like you could see
the top of your deck like above your
pants if you tuck your shirt over if
you're not wearing a shirt oh then yeah
you see that alien from Prometheus
staring at you I feel like they're just
the very tip of it as many open the door
for it would take me like a cold 10
seconds to be like what am I looking at
I uh the one that I actually wanted to
bring is called Brussels sprouts man at
flagship Whole Foods with dark brown
hair which I do a voice you do voices on
the show you smiled you smiled at me
when I got in the fast lane you were a
few people ahead of me you had a bag of
what looked to be 10,000 Brussels
sprouts or at least 10 bags in one big
bag you checked out and started to walk
away as I came to the same checker you
turned around to change directions and
smiled at me one last time
then walked away forever it is in all
caps oh where are you going and what are
you doing with all those Brussels
sprouts
Brussels be s party Brussels
party I like them too and I have a good
recipe or two I could share with you
chances are you'll never see this as I
don't think these misconnections either
what I say don't look at these missed
connections either I hope you enjoy the
sprouts though smiling case and it
doesn't say man for a woman or anything
either no this one's like very pure it's
actually very cute it's really just a
person being like hey we bond we bonded
accidentally of my love of you having
thousands of processes which it's
probably like some fucked-up thing like
you can like doing all this [ __ ] up
from someone buying like a cucumber and
and then like seeing this post in being
like [ __ ] someone saw me don't think
they have the structural integrity like
stay put if you inserted them in you but
they also kind of peel so I feel like
you lose a lot immune you open it again
so I could yeah sure uh yeah Brussels
sprouts also smell like [ __ ] when you
warm them up so I met my baby like I
always thought I didn't like them until
I had them like you know like fried or
whatever it is really Christie's like
like I don't really like them whole in
salads or whatever mm-hmm I think
they're actually kind of like bitter or
almost yeah I had a dish originally I
ordered a an order of like crispy
Brussels sprouts and they came out and
they were moist Brussels sprouts and
then it was rough yeah I'm gonna bake
I'm the same way with bacon
yeah well I'm Bacon's great but I wanted
to be moist I want to be Chris Christie
we mostly have like moist ish bacon in
Australia it's like Canadian bacon yeah
which I'm like cool with it what I want
that fake in with that but when I want
like crispy bacon then someone brings me
moist I just get annoyed when bacon has
like strings of fat on it and then
you're like trying to eat it and you're
like oh well I'm really just chewing
food now and it's fighting against me
this sucks
that's why if it's crispy just after at
all but I never had crispy bacon before
moving to the US not once it is a u.s.
thing probably yeah cuz if you have it
like when I have crispy bacon in Europe
alight with Europe it's like super just
burnt like it's like it's like we don't
well just literally one
yeah so anyway jerky getting back to the
story and less about how we gonna bacon
it says you smiled at me when I got into
falling you're a few people ahead of me
mm-hmm well when I got into falling so
it's like there were three people who
were lined up around 10,000 Brussels
sprouts I mean me honest you guys I
think 10,000 like might be an
exaggeration um possibly it's way
funnier if you picture actually ten
thousand working that's like 30 I'm also
not imagining them in bags I'm just
imagining like the Brussels sprouts just
open on this oh my I'm 100% imagining
them I have my individual balls of
Brussels sprouts that he's like put in a
trolley and they keep falling but that
means that like this the the smile is
what makes me like Andrews theory is
that it mentions that it says you smiled
at me two separate times yeah he turned
around like a knowing smile of like you
know you aware of it you into that kind
of [ __ ] so in he turned around to change
directions and smiled at me one last
time so then did he go the wrong way
well then walked away forever right but
like where was he going and I went
around to change directions and smiled
at me one last time and walked away for
about like that's like that word like
you're walking towards the door and let
me like turn around and do like a
backwards walking wave and then turn
back around it's not what it was I'm
sure geographically I'm trying to figure
out and also is the fast lane a
self-checkout no I've been you been in
this whole foods it's the one that they
have no weight oh oh oh so I think they
have a they have a staircase so maybe he
went out towards the stairs and then
turned around to go down the stairs or
whatever
very good distance he was fast lane
express lane like 10,000 items or less I
think it has me confused it says you
checked out and started to walk away as
I came to the same check up but so first
it says you were a few people ahead of
me second it says you checked out and I
came to the same check oh so it makes it
sound like maybe the person in the
middle was like weirded out by this
strange Brussels sprout lust well maybe
that both while the Brussels sprouts of
that
both rubbing men dicks so here comes
just like if I can be here at all Murr
correctly the fasten I think you walked
up and there's four registers you can go
to so so me know the people in front of
her the other okay so it's like Brussels
sprouts guy checks out here then the
next person kicks out here yeah and this
person checks out here again yeah so the
changing directions and walking away is
still very confusing but it just sounds
like he started leaving turned around
they make eye contact again then he got
a boner and then he got a boner this one
is two men I don't know why what if this
is the same guy what if this is the guy
that delivered to the man with the boner
Josh with diarrhea
I got it's all one is awesome adventure
what Russell sparks proud of Russ Russ
Brussels sprouts
Brussels sprouts party Brussels / no you
had it Brussels sprouts parties yes God
do you think they exist uh yeah if pizza
parties exist hey what's the weirdest
themed party you've ever been to themed
party yeah like the strangest theme any
super weird ones I was at so this isn't
really a weird theme you know those did
your college have those like red light
green light ropes like if you're single
you're a green if you're like kind of
dating so not super yellow and if you're
taking more red so like there's one of
those in college but like I always
thought it was were to go to one of
those parties and someone's not wearing
one of those three colors like someone's
wearing like purple and you're like
alright wow yeah I always wanted to do a
Rubik's Cube party the idea being that
you have to wear different colors from a
Rubik's Cube and by the end of the night
you are supposed to be wearing entirely
one color so the point is that you
constantly swap clothes with people well
like the stipulation would be like oh
make sure that you have something that
underneath like you can get changing
you're comfortable in it don't like just
like up bezzie dick what if what if
you're like a very small person and you
need a pair of pants but that would make
it that funny - I guess I'm worth like
you would be wearing giant pants and
like holding them up will Michael like
oh you're wearing entirely red good job
you want it's a really good idea I think
you're really fun wait so then you'd
have to bring six articles of clothes
of different colors yeah that's did you
come up with that idea it's a good idea
I don't know maybe but then what if
everyone shows up wearing only green
there are different things okay so it's
like I I wouldn't say you have to
westlakes but you all have to wear like
different items of clothes like a hat
sure did you have a sign-up sheet where
you say hey no so the point is that no
one everyone is going to succeed that's
the thing like everyone's going to try
to some people will fail yeah I get too
competitive I wouldn't be able oh yeah
you'd like to beat someone up you like
punch someone in the face do they give
me a wide shot even as the delivery guy
who's not even there for the party I
also want to back away up and just say a
Brussels sprouts party literally like so
even if this exists and even if you have
10,000 Brussels sprouts and it's not for
any weird-ass stuff and you invite
hundred people over to cook brussel
sprouts what is that party other than
ice literally everyone's impacted your
apartment whether you cook 10,000
Brussels from you watch the VeggieTales
oh yeah you really embrace the vegetable
and then you put Brussels sprouts right
yeah well maybe the point is like that
but like it's a huge Brussels sprout
party but like it's it's like a cooking
activity and it's like you have to
prepare the most interesting Brussels
sprout and then just happen to be like
you know five thousand people going so
they're like it's like a huge
competition a couple you guys don't know
about it how does the Dissidia not know
about it and then you have to like
giving them up and be like oh I made
chocolate glazed Brussels sprouts was
awful
yeah they're I'm pretty bad yeah we went
to a Tater Tot Festival so I feel like
it's not too often it's like surely some
someone at that festival maybe
collectively has to go buy ten thousand
tater tots yeah yeah which are called
potato gems in Australia fun fact
disgusting I like the name potato tots
is so much fun a lot the tongue yeah it
touched the Tater Tot that i d't ate a
pot I don't like it's just taters a
tater tots I don't like that much so
this this story we need to give this bus
in a name which person Russell Russell
the Brussels right yeah yeah so we've
just
sited they both men I think it's so much
fun like it's a really creepy story to
me if it's a woman buying the Brussels
sprouts and this guy just staring or
vice versa if the woman is in line well
whoever did it was smiling the the
Brussels sprout bio was the one smiling
at the other person but rue I pretty
often smile at strangers in a way that's
just like if I make eye contact with
someone I'll just smile at them like I
do the white people grin right up shogi
exactly and you do that we had smile so
it's like maybe it could be that like
maybe this person was like intently
staring at these Brussels sprouts and
was just like why they buying something
yeah and this person does this every the
other person does it every week so they
just do the white post and smile what
everyone that it's like okay why
everyone just doesn't me when I come to
this specific Whole Foods I don't know
why you're smiling everyone mm-hmm so
we're going with we're on the assumption
it's gross dude named Russell so we've
got died by Ranna it was like iron or
something and then so so it'll be
Russell Russell
yeah well Russell Brussels the one
that's he's the delivery guy but he's
also the guy behind the Brussels sprouts
yeah I'm gonna call the boner guy
buh-buh-buh-buh yeah yeah you are up
okay what you got worse mind from New
York City it's called woman crying on
Queens Boulevard no no you were the
woman crying on Queens Boulevard and
Broadway on Sunday night May 27 at 11:40
you had curly brownish blondish hair and
you were carrying several packages and
bags and sobbing and crying while you
were walking around the corner not far
from a food cart what were you crying
about so what I what I like about this
post is a couple things number one the
specificity is fantastic because I
thought at the time yeah like I see a
lot of when I was looking for this I
read a lot of posts that were like
varying they were like you were at Whole
Foods buying a bunch of Brussels sprouts
it doesn't have like a day of the week
like a time it's like not exactly so I
really like that that's in there I also
love that he freely mentions the food
cart like so near food my favorite
mystery of this entire thing is if he's
implying that that's involved in this
woman so maybe she was crying dude over
sanity to a food card that can be
and that's how I think about it but you
know I do like that this would I'd like
about this post is it wasn't like it no
it never says you were really hot it
never says it ends with what were you
crying about and what I like about it is
that it's expressing concern and like
this is one of the only posts I found
that wasn't like I saw you and got a
boner or like I saw anything you were
hot it's just like wow you were really
sad like what's up like I want to help
you
totally I think you interpreted that but
for me I was like what are you crying
about New York crying about it how long
does it say it was posted I'd say they
were supposed to try to figure out like
how many days do you recommend like
three days later well like it's from it
was from today and it was that's like a
while ago so they took four days to be
like exactly they're just sitting there
thinking about like I mean there's the
40 yeah you think like maybe it's like
it kind of like this plus and just
compulsively feels the need to check the
time anytime they see someone crying
yeah like you look away to look at why
it's also you were carrying several bags
and packages like again I'm picturing
somebody carrying ten baths and Brussels
sprouts or something like how many bags
whistles Emeril I also get the image of
the ham Sophie and then while picturing
this woman with curly hair sobbing Stan
the hotdog cart holding four bags and
it's just bags and packages so it's like
a sack full of boxes while holding a bag
in another bag another day I wonder if
she if you saw someone in that situation
on the road with a bunch of bags and
packages like my head would go to
they've been like left that partner and
because they moved out totally gonna say
that yeah they just went through a
breakup or they just got fired at the
other desk at 11:40 p.m. next to a food
cart yeah me I would just have like all
of these statues and foxes they'd be
like to the girl who had several Batman
oh my god terrible but it's alright that
makes me think that maybe it could be
like romantic in nature if it's like you
probably just went through a breakup you
want to go back to that truck that was
there and hang out like like she's
caring all the packages
break up seize the food cart where they
they met because they both cut boners
starts sobbing at the memories it's a
manhole woman it does I think oh it
doesn't it just says that straight this
could be a woman also it does not say
men for women my mind goes to the night
might be homeless
potentially do you think oh I guess but
you why would you put a misconnection
for a like if a homeless person is
crying and has a lot of bags and
packages homeless what floor but they
might not have known that or something
but yeah yes it could be homeless yeah I
don't know it's a salty it's depressing
yeah someone crying at 11:40 p.m. while
right next to food that they are eating
is very sick right there I really do
like your interpretation of it better
than mine because I was like oh this is
so sweet
you're like you [ __ ] dirty well if I
see someone crying on the street I think
I'm gonna have this conversation on the
show for I don't know I like did you
consult them do you you can sold it do
you can tell no one else so I've
definitely been like are you okay two
people who were crying and got snapped
at oh really
everything happens like what's the
stranger on just like I've like been on
the subway or whatever and someone's
like literally crying and I'm like are
you okay and they're like I'm fine talk
about it make sure but you can also be
like I'm fine just healing through some
stuff like you just like nicely brushed
them off it's not like it like going to
the forehead like knock-knock are you
crying about yeah yeah well Andrews
always really rude though so the thing
is probably yelled at them yeah
hyper-aggressive
we know and like gesturing take their
headphones out like oh okay wow this is
unnecessary I'm fine but I like have
consult many crying girls and drunk
bathrooms at clubs that's a thing that
happens pretty often I think I might
have told this on the show for I
remember but I the one time that I
yelled at someone for telling me to
smile on the street was like two days
off to Chelsea died and I just obviously
would have looked miserable and a guy
was like you should smile and I was like
my [ __ ] dog died he was like oh
what things could happen to I don't
remember what he chose but I was like
get [ __ ] like I'm not doing this today
but I nothing anyone's ever told me
while crying I don't know I feel like
all right
which I don't cry a ton yeah I don't
think that I would would be I don't know
if someone tried to comfort me while I
was crying in public I would say thank
you I don't want to talk about it that
would say it's definitely you're totally
right that's how someone asks because
it's like if you see someone crying in
your reaction isn't to say hey are you
okay it's go why you're trying it's like
[ __ ] you like it's not like it's not
like you don't know you you would
probably rather be smiling too I was
like I'm sad but my shots cute and
someone was like oh there's nothing to
be that sad about like you're so
privileged like hazel this good stuff
was happening and I just replied to it
it was like someone that I deeply care
about is very sick and I like didn't
elaborate but I was just like I'm what
like I'm not gonna give you I'm not
gonna give you that one
it's like it's it's very complicated
shit's never that easy I wouldn't be
above like if I was really going through
some [ __ ] and crying in public I'd
probably hug a person that came out to
mean asses you know right if he was
offered up haha yeah it depends the a
couple of days off to Chelsea died I
went to a doctor's appointment that was
a dog in the office and I patted the dog
command I went to work and I started
crying in the kitchen and it was like
the I hadn't told anyone at that point
like no one at work knew that she had
died and John Ryan was in the kitchen
and I just started he was like how are
you I didn't go on to tell anyone after
that I was like I feel so sorry but it's
like the [ __ ] I just dumped on that
man just because he happen to ask me how
I was especially because like 99% of the
time when I pass somebody in the kitchen
I'm like how you doing they're good all
right you look good and that's after
like the thing they love most on the
planet is dead and then just like oh my
god respectively it's we near fruit
Cartman Boston what do you even work Wow
we get bagels on Wednesdays oh yeah we
get lunch every Monday morning it's
Levins breakfast so much every I gotta
go
okay I don't know if this one counts as
a missed connection do you think the
person is trying to approach them hit on
them or are they literally just up at
night being like I think it's that I
think it's concerned like I really I
don't get the impression this is what
were you crying about dot dot dot do you
want to [ __ ] sometimes like I don't
think it's that is the reason that yeah
I genuinely think this at least how I
read it on Craigslist yeah and that's
the thing like I like that they aren't
they're just like you had brownish hair
and you were crying and like there's not
a ton of like and sweet to see like
that's why I chose this cuz like I read
so many that were more like that every
day you were in the Train looked really
sad and had a rocking bod that's like I
think this one bug feels very at least
how I read it feels very innocent how
you read it it's just like me under the
New York scope yeah god man so many of
these are uber drivers just wanted to
hook up with people to think affairs who
I think story I told on the first yeah
there's that and then I also saw I saw
one that was kind of close to the one
that you just read which was like like
David who had a stroke hey you had a
stroke I called the cops for you hope
you're doing okay yeah yeah and I think
that's nice but it's it's yours do it
like your dog won it's like they want to
know if everything's okay that gets like
they were like yawn and they were to
spork no they definitely wanted to find
what you think so it's I think he said
his name was Josh but that's all I know
because this one is from the it's the
perspective of the woman for the man and
it says this nice cute guy help him okay
yeah she's definitely trying to track
down Josh and be like hey do you want to
hang out me and my car all right we need
to give them a name the woman crying or
the person posting supposed to be from
the person posting it's giving it the
name I think I don't even remember
do whatever you want nerville's it's
really New York name it's on Queens
Boulevard could be Queenie well I when
you read it you know like woman crying
on Queens I was gonna be like Adrienne
granny is perfect it's a drink this is
the last episode of Entourage a
reference to I am you could totally
mistaken for a woman
it also says curly he was crying his
entourage just make he couldn't fight
his blu-ray said he's on my mind right
now because for whatever reason the and
New Zealand flight presentation he's
hosted by Adrian Grenier
yeah and it is very they're no they're
in and talk to come it's so weird the
entire video is like is it like oh yeah
it's like the entree yeah no it's it's
like like a bunch of kids at school and
then Adrian Grenier shows up and he's
like it's like ACTA activist Adrian
grinia and he's like they see some
penguins me like goes for a look and I'm
looking up what he's doing these days
aside from that one and New Zealand
commercial but yeah because he's in
Antarctica like why are they shooting a
safety video with Adrian Grenier yeah he
did a TV movie was it called love at
first glance sounds like a lifetime yeah
sounds like a Craigslist misconnection
weed and there's like this these all
these like Kiwi kids in a school and one
of them is like hey Adrian you should
take a selfie and he's like that's a
great idea and takes a selfie with some
penguins and it's like wise I could die
on this plane if you don't tell me how
to use my app how does the seatbelt lock
I really want to see that it's so weird
well this guy's name is definitely a
jury in them it's Adrian Grenier yeah
sure um so this is the photo show we
discuss who is the most likely to
succeed and that depends on what that
goal is the one who's posting to Adrian
Grenier is to find out why I was sad why
why they're sad and kind of as I read it
like are you okay yeah find out why they
were okay um I mean diet diary knee once
to I think a track down Josh and B have
a date with Josh both with Boehner wants
to find out who his delivery person is
probably have sex and then rustle this
lady we have to go with we have to go
with Russell you consciously throw the
second one at the end conversation okay
it's Russell Russ starts right Russell
wants to find or like the lady what's
fun Russell the Russell doesn't say or
the demand wants find Russell Russell
where are you going and what are you
doing with all those Brussels sprouts
yeah uh yeah and I could share recipes
with you so that's tracking them down
today finding out about the Rasta sprout
potty and dating seem so because yours
has a name and a physical description I
would imagine that yours the most I
think mine's really likely because how
okay if you had Josh and you hold a dog
while a woman is cleaning up diarrhea in
a will be pakka I think that's probably
a story that you tell multiple people
off the woods you're like oh my god the
weirdest thing happened to me today plus
it's specific it's not a Warby Parker
it's specifically the one in the domain
and yours is like that specifically mine
is just a food cart and it gives an
intersection but it's like they're
probably four or five different food
carts and counterpoint how often do you
go back to a War II Parker as opposed to
your grocery store this guy's gonna be
coming back to that Whole Foods and
there's my that's a good but I don't
think going back there would hope the
point is he just needs to like find out
the post exists yeah needs to be like oh
my god this is totally about you because
no one else has had to hold a dog that
had diarrhea and won't be pocket before
yeah so it's like I think that it's it's
easier to find this guy on the Internet
okay but also if you contact Whole Foods
they're like hey did somebody buy all
wrestle sprouts but you have recently Oh
Russell you're talking about I think
that one's unlikely because I like
running on the assumption that it's a
person who's just buying their Brussels
sprouts and someone's like wow that's a
lot and maybe it's just like twenty and
they think that that's a ton and then
just like doing that like okay this is
kind of weird smile hmm so that it's
like mm-hmm anyway by like that we had
it out this guy I don't think like well
you have to question the guy that's
holding the dog his motive cuz like if
he was like trying to be helpful
might've been because she was a cute
girl or he's just trying to be helpful
like hopefully the dog yeah we can't
like say that he would necessarily want
to date but like it seems most likely to
me that they could at least that he
could see this post yeah like that seems
the most likely also yeah
if he's gonna miss again it was a real
Brussels fest like the tatertot festival
we went to
and everyone's like oh yeah this is
obviously the guy who supplies the
Brussels sprouts we all know him
Brussels Dave
I bet the Rings him every year I bet
they'll they'll run into each other in
the future at Whole Foods though I don't
think that she'll find I don't think
he's gonna find this post and that's
gonna have they're gonna be connected
again but I bet they'll run into each
other again
do you grocery shop on the same macdanne
time every week yeah
same time different days to be a grocery
interesting I like mostly a lot of food
if I'm traveling Oh see I like yeah well
definitely when I'm like not around a
lot but like when I'm you like around
for a few weeks out go grocery shopping
but sometimes after work sometimes it's
Sunday mornings sometimes it's like I
will say this but this also goes to this
person's point Austin's a small enough
city that I run into people I know all
the time so I bet these two are probably
then you got New York over here well
that's the thing with New York right
especially like if you're near like a
subway station like that person might
never come back there come back there
once a year so it's like it what also
seems like if we're right that Adrian
Grenier was moving out yeah that's being
kicked out of his apartment was like
something during the day you're more
likely to be like after work or like
around words like 11:40 p.m. it's not
like you're coming from work right so
just that if you were the person who
read that post
I wouldn't reply if I if someone was
like hey this person was asking why you
I got a boner and the delivery guy
didn't get his name it was really
awkward and I took my packages out like
I wouldn't I would not respond to that
post like Wester why would you validate
that response unless you also at exactly
1141 you were crying were like oh my god
I saw the most beautiful I read a
statistic that like several million
people have a boner at any one point in
time which [ __ ] yeah it's also people
who fought it'll be like millions of
people fought in unison isn't it like
point since I had any minute of any day
some work someone the plane is having
sex all right to get back on track we
are ordering diarrhea E is the most
likely Brussels sprout e mmm-hmm Russell
ii and then he who seeks adrian grenier
yeah it's third i grew that
I feel pretty good about this and then
if we're gonna check Boeing that someone
that once was [ __ ] up yeah I think
he'll yeah you'll hear from him in like
in court because he exposed his penis I
know two people who started dating is it
well I guess for by favor deliveries
yeah really
favor but like deliveries Wow and one of
them is like wait was it I'm sorry
what's a favored favor yeah your power
post mates oh yeah one of them is like a
girl who's a very well-known DJ and she
started she met her boyfriend because he
delivered a food well that's kind of
cute yeah I buy that it's true it's
great because it did it did happen I
wasn't lying
no no I'm not saying yeah but it's just
like that's the it to you yeah yeah I
don't know how a conversation like that
goes like I mama is really cute
okay well that might be how that comes
really just like hey you keep I'm was
just fascinated by people who were like
yeah like we met cuz they were a barista
at the coffee shop or whatever cuz I'd
like I would no matter how cute I
thought someone working in a coffee shop
was I would feel so shitty bothering
someone at work like never never like be
like hi lava grande iced coffee also
you're really cute like I can't imagine
ever doing that there's such like well I
bet it's like really quick passive like
I'm gonna shot in the dark like here's
the number I know you're in a rush and
then it probably goes from okay yeah so
I've done that before the only time I've
ever given someone when my number like
in a boss setting was a bartender and my
mom and I were at the bar and he was
making a strings all night and I got to
a point where like we were very drunk
and I wasn't asking what I wanted
anymore I was just like I like sweet
drinks so he was making me drinks and
didn't end up charging us for any of the
drinks he made me so because of that I
took that as like this he is buying me
drinks yeah that's right so I left my
number on a napkin and like gave to him
oh that's long back yeah he texted me
how did it go I never texted him I was
like what's his name
where is he now he's a bomb honey like
he was really nice like he I decided
that he probably thought that I was
older than I was
oh he would have been like 35 or so okay
and I think at the time I was 21 yeah
it was something along those lines that
I was like he probably thought I was
because people generally think I'm all
of the Nights gonna say like he got past
the hold meeting the parents part of
this my mom was that the whole time yeah
that was fine that's also weird I've
never but I was the one who gave the
number like he was making hydrants all
night too but like I mean he charged a
weird one recently when I was in Japan
Brian melkowitz and I we were in a store
and got approached two girls who'd spoke
fairly broken English who kept saying
they wanted to take us to a temple and
we didn't know what that meant
like and eventually they added us me on
Twitter him on Facebook and deemed us
from the entire trip Wow try at first we
were like oh they're flirting with us
but by the end of it we thought they
were like Scientologists where was this
in Japan like a Scientologist breakfast
that goes down during e3 what probably
apparently every year that happens to be
during e3 was like a big open house
Scientologists breakfast thing that
sometimes a bunch of people in the games
industry will go to it like out of
curiosity weird I've always thought like
it's like one of those like III folklore
things like that's like incredible like
the kind of funny body lost yeah
everyone talked about that I'll be in a
sex dungeon like this time it's like wow
this is like Scientology breakfast that
all these people go dude Tim shape is
I'm sure temperature is not bad like my
bad but like it's like people like talk
about it like Jeff keel ego it's like
apparently like a pretty sweet boy if
you're hungover you're just like all
right well let's go to the Church of
Scientology and then Tom Cruise yeah
yeah Will Smith Tom Cruise Tim shakey
Lee the whole group all right I feel
like you know we're gonna probably get
in some trouble now because I've just
named a bunch of people I'm just
imagining Jeff Keeley slowly taking off
his headphones there she sorry Jeff big
fan we'll send you a t-shirt no I feel
like people are gonna tweet them too
very nice guy and probably not a
scientist if he is that's totally okay
Jeff it's entertaining not because I'm
not going inside everyone who does this
episode who is a Scientologist like see
the [ __ ] away for bookbag Oh see the
other one see all the [ __ ] hash wow
thanks Jeff yeah and where are those
Brussels sprouts we said that guy
Russell he's still in Texas you never
made it better
we'll have Boehner's callbacks for
Connor
oh boy anyway this is the show where we
talk about where people can find you on
the Internet wait where are you at only
into it uh Twitter and Instagram oh do I
need to myself I mean you don't have to
it just like plug yourself at Biggles
for Twitter and the underscore Blaine
for Instagram this is what happened to
be Gibble's on Instagram I used to have
that domain and then they said that I
broke some rule and then they banned me
but I honestly don't know what it was
was it all the nudes I don't know what
happened with all those pictures of your
testicles cutting any oh no everyone
knows I'm darf up on Twitter and I write
on IGN it's about everything yeah I mean
well I don't know if we can like you
know this show is gonna go up before e3
and it's gonna be like we can plug much
III stuff that we'll be doing but like I
have so many things that I don't think I
can even say what they are yeah dudes
conferences yes so beyond ign.com yeah
we're really excited about it actually
animating on recording a whole bunch
more episodes wine bank leasing with
like including with like Lucy O'Brian
mm-hmm and scrabbles and like a bunch of
like very very cool people so that'll be
fun everyone you can follow the podcast
on Twitter and on Instagram at a local
podcast it's also olive podcast.com
and we will see you in a couple of weeks
bye bye